Film Courage: Why do people fail in Hollywood?
Alex Munoz, Filmmaker and Founder of FYI Films:
I actually think more people fail in Hollywood
than succeed because it's a game and what
people don't understand is the game changes
every day.
You have to know how the machine works.
If you don't know how the machine works you're
not going to get your work out there and you
will not have doors opening for your success.
Also I think some people stumble and fail
because they haven't taken the time to develop
their craft as storytellers and filmmakers.
You really have to have it down.
You really have to know craft.
You have to know where to put the camera,
what lens to use, what is the lighting, what
is the rhythm, tempo and pacing, what is being
revealed in the scene, where is the climax,
where is the point of ignition, where is the
aftermath, where does it pick up again and
where does it end?
You have to know these things otherwise you’re
going to have a really hard time making a
successful film.
It’s craft, craft, craft, craft, craft and
the best way to learn filmmaking is go out
and make films.
Every time you make a film you learn.
I am still learning.
I feel like I just scratched the surface in
terms of what is it to make a good film.
Film Courage: I like what you say about how
the rules change.
I hadn’t really thought of that.
That’s really interesting.
So then how does somebody start to know what
the rules are if no one is telling you but
they are changing?
Alex: You have to circulate and read the trades.
You have to be informed.
You have to gather intelligence.
I’m not going to mention names but there
is an actor who recently fell from grace and
he was attached to a project of mine.
That project is now gone because his fall
was so dark and tragic and severe and toxic.
So the game changed with my relationship with
this actor because of what happened.
Things are changing every day.
I pitched a series to a network that was ready
to be greenlit and the day we were supposed
to sign the papers the channel hired a new
person to take over and this new person said
“I’m not green lighting any project that
my predecessor greenlit so I am sorry you
are going to have to pitch this to someone
else.”
Changes.
I had another TV show where I had two very
famous show runners a week before we were
supposed to go sign the deal one of them got
named to run a network.
But you don’t cry and weep about these things.
You go Okay this wasn’t meant to be.
Let’s keep going, keep going.
It changes every day and you have to be informed.
You have to gather intelligence and talk to
people in the industry and read the trades.
Question for the viewers: Did you view pursuing
a Hollywood career as a game?